wait a minute kill mongers fathers in
this oh yeah yeah oh I'm sure we can
trace all buncha Tran masters in this
Dirac's is in this amout of people the
mummies in hello Magnus sites
Heiko a family you ready to get stuck
mine eyes we're gonna watch today a
trailer from global Road and Warner
Brothers called a hotel Artemus this is
from director drew Pierce who was the
co-writer for Iron Man 3 he also worked
on story for rogue nation I don't know
anything about it it has a giant cast
and that's about as far as it goes for
me it's a patient of the day shout out
today for Niraj Krishnan man from New
Jersey who's always requesting weird ass
looking movies indie trailers and
esoterica nano you discovered us from
the jab eco a channel who is my
biological brother but Niraj i want you
to know that i am way better than Jabbok
away in every aspect of the world
especially at taking in and assessing
Indian content especially at that I
think what you got to do right now is go
to Jabba ko a channel unsubscribe
immediately let him know you
unsubscribed because you prefer his
better brother and then tells me that
you'll subscribe to get Jabby if he has
greg on at least once every every week
Thank You Niraj I hope you appreciated
your shout out it had nothing to do
about me it was all about you the entire
time next time we're in New York we're
gonna pay you a visit yeah I still feel
bad I wasn't able to link up with you
and I was out there so I owe you one bud
Jon that's what Jon journals every day I
wish I'd made that work I'm sure Roger
can't wait to see the calm this is skip
to this time to go check out the trailer
you don't want to support but you do
want to view the content
yeah okay this is gonna be interesting
the perch sterling Cape round
[Music]
Hospital for criminals yeah this is the
content
[Music]
don't push my buttons no this woman
she's the business if you knew what she
could do to you with just that cup of
coffee
you're lucky this places rules about 18
million okay problem breakers I got it
good cool
yeah Wow what a cast we can do it
together this is what I do
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's it's it's John wick meets it's John
wakes hospital it's the Continental
meets assault on precinct 13 yeah that's
the total vibe I get I bet you right now
if we scroll through some comments and
be like Continental protocols it's all
where the criminals go there's a truce
that exists in this property I would I
would never call this a ripoff of John
wick though I mean maybe there's an
inspired semi concept from the content
on but the content was only an aspect to
the John way story it's not the thing
whereas this is this is like the whole
story were to take place at the
Continental which makes it a totally
different type of thing because quality
yeah at the continent and it's also
sci-fi as well it looks kind of designed
like the future but the action and [ __ ]
looks like it's no it's Sons and knives
it's 2028 and they got like scientific
technology it doesn't look like crazy
out of this world
yeah but it was but it's definitely
there speaking of Kingsman you got sofia
boutella
reprising the role she always plays
maybe show at least get you know like a
decent amount of dialogue or some kind
of importance in this movie because i
feel like a lot of movies kind of get
her to be there and yeah cool and do her
thing and only about half of them ever
like really let her shine Bryan Tyree
Henry from Atlanta in this - yeah he's
great on that show and like you know I
was wondering when I was gonna see him
popping up in movies and stuff sterling
K Brown I'm happy he actually has this
role because he's like the action lead
male actually looks like sofia boutella
is the female action lead and certainly
kate brown gets a chance to really kick
some ass cuz that's the trajectory if
you're gonna be a big actors you know
you'd be a powerful dramatic actor that
you go into action roles like you know
oh cool
it's gonna be nice to maybe see him
kicking ass instead of just really a
moding Jodie Foster look amazing yeah
actually she's one of the most exciting
parts of this trailer to me honestly
like I just love the look of whatever
this you know kooky characters you know
she kind of reminds me of like a more
mellow Edna from the Incredible you know
like making gear she was some kind of
surgeon or some kind of doctor yeah
Charlie Day as an arms dealer I'm not
entirely sure how people will respond to
that I feel like I can buy it I feel
like I tend to like Charlie Day and
weirder roles like this more than most
people Corky and I feel like especially
after you know Pacific Rim and stuff
like that if I can see us all buying him
as a heightened you know chromatic I
really you know cocaine is big in the
crime world and he's got a lot of energy
so there you go that's the Jeff Goldblum
chewing up some scenery
well more what you want from this man
this looks like a fun sci-fi action
contain entertaining ass film you know I
feel like this is really wanna be
anything more than that yeah like this
is gonna reinvent any wheels but I feel
like this might be one of those you know
stylish crime movies that comes out and
everybody seizes like yes cool the only
thing I would have set me about this
movie is it I found out it was rated
pg-13 that was an interesting ass
trailer that's not it's nice to see a
unique movie coming out here you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about because
subscribe buttons don't me anything and
you can check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is over there would love to have you